after a lightning offensive in
nagorno-karabakh azerbaijan's president
claims full control of the disputed
region with ethnic Armenian forces
agreeing to lay down their weapons
as a result of the start of the
anti-terrorist measures Azerbaijan has
restored its sovereignty the events that
occurred yesterday and today at the same
time will have a positive impact on the
peace process between Armenia and
Azerbaijan I want to hope that our steps
the results of anti-terrorist measures
will eliminate the obstacles that were
put forward Express proposed call it
what you want from The Armenian side and
this will create a new reality long-term
peace in the South Caucasus
this enclave and self-declared Breakaway
territory is internationally recognized
as passive Azerbaijan but it's been
controlled by ethnic Armenians and has
close links to The Armenian government
it's perceived failure to support the
territory particularly after a war in
2020 sparked protests in the capital
Yerevan internal enemy uh
rejected to support Armenia citizens who
are now living there so this is a shame
of our nation it's something that we've
been
fighting for 30 years more than 30 years
and now it all went for nothing amini is
prime minister denied having troops in
the garden of karabakh and said his
government was not part of the ceasefire
process
we hope the military escalation will not
continue because stability is very
important for future projects
both Armenia and Azerbaijan have gone to
war over the region since the early
1990s Russian peacekeepers will monitor
the new ceasefire and Azerbaijan says it
will now start talks on reintegrating
the region and its people Alex beard Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera